You know,
this is something my wife has pointed
out to.
She said,
well,
men are going to have to stand up for
themselves,
but here's the problem.
I know how to stand up to a man who's,
who's,
uh,
unfairly trespassing against me.
And the reason I know that is because
the parameters for my resistance are
quite well defined,
which is we talk,
we argue,
we push,
and then it becomes physical,
right?
Like if,
if we move beyond the boundaries of
civil discourse,
we know what the next step is,
okay,
that's forbidden in,
in discourse with women.
And so I don't think that men can
control crazy women.
I don't think.
I really don't believe that.
I think that they have to throw their
hands up in,
in,
in what,
in.
It's not even disbelief.
It's that the cultural,
there's no step forward that you can
take under those circumstances because
if the man is offensive enough and crazy
enough,
the reaction becomes physical right
away.
Or at least the threat is there.
And when men are talking to each other
in any serious manner,
that underlying thread of physicality is
always there.
Especially if it's a real conversation
and it keeps the thing.
Civil Law is to some degree,
you know,
if you're talking to a man who wouldn't
fight with you under any circumstances
whatsoever,
then you're talking to someone to whom
you have absolutely no respect,
but I can't see any way.
For example,
there's a,
there's a woman in in Toronto who's been
organizing this movement,
let's say against me and some other
people who are going to do a free speech
event and she managed to organize quite
effectively and she's quite offensive.
You might say.
She compared us to Nazis,
for example,
which,
you know,
publicly using the swastika,
which wasn't really something I was all
that fond of,
but I,
I'm defenseless against that kind of
female insanity because the techniques
that I would use against a man who is
employing those tactics are forbidden to
me.
So I don't know.
Like it seems to me that it isn't man
that have to stand up and say enough of
this even though that is what they
should do.
It seems to me that it's same women who
have to stand up against their crazy
sisters and say,
look,
enough of that enough man hating enough
pathology,
enough bringing disgrace on us as a,
as a gender,
but the problem there and then they'll
stop.
My little tirade is that most of the
women I know who are saying are busy
doing saying things right.
They're off.
They have their career,
they have their family,
they're quite occupied and they don't
seem to have the time or maybe even the
interest to go after their crazy
heartbeat sisters and so I don't see any
regulating force for that.
That terrible femininity and it seems to
me to be invading the culture and
undermining the masculine power of the
culture in a way that's,
I think fatal.